il reste l'un des incontournables
châteaux de la loire chambord continue
d'attirer les vacanciers visites
organisées ou simple arrêt sur la route
des vacances tous sont émerveillés on en
prend plein les yeux c'est magnifique ça
faisait très longtemps qu'on voudrait
faire les châteaux de la loire donc là
aujourd'hui on fait chambord et demain
chenonceau c'est très très beau c'est
vraiment magnifique appris et beaucoup
beaucoup de monde
j'ai du coup on essaye déjà de pas se
perdre les français sont donc les
visiteurs principaux pour la deuxième
année consécutive
si chambord est habitué à ces touristes
étrangers ils ne représentent que 20%
des entrées les étrangers reviennent
aussi petit à petit avec en particulier
des america bonds les dernières mesures
peuvent peut-être changé et puis les
pays limitrophes comme toujours un
retour des espagnols et des italiens
j'espère que mon groupe me suis bien en
juillet jusqu'à 6000 personnes par jour
découvrez l'histoire du château le mois
d'août est tout aussi prometteur pour le
plus grand plaisir que personnel la
salle du roi c'était une salle de
réception on va aller voir comment c'est
fait tout de suite c'est le mieux venez
on a un public très nombreux on s'en
réjouit d'ailleurs beaucoup c'est ce qui
nous fait vivre à la fois les guides les
personnels d'entretien tout le château
et on est ravi d'avoir ce public
nombreux qui contribuent à la longévité
et notamment du domaine de chambord
la météo et le pass annie terre n'ont
donc pas découragé les férus d'histoire
fermée pendant de longs mois chambord
connais cet été sa renaissance
[Musique]